Encuentra el producto 2x más 8 por 2x -8. Esto básicamente es una multiplicación de binomios así que podríamos resolverla
utilizando el método FOIL o la propiedad distributiva. Sin embargo creo que el punto del problema es ver si podemos
reconocer un patrón, si podemos reconocer que este producto es de la forma "a" más "b", por "a" -"b"
y en efecto lo es ¿Verdad? Si "a" es 2x y "b" es 8 entonces aquí tenemos
"a" más "b" y aquí tenemos "a" - "b" . Déjame desarrollar esto de acá utilizando la propiedad
distributiva y luego lo que nos queda lo aplicamos para este ¿Vale?
Entonces voy a distribuir este "a" más "b" con este "a" y luego con este - "b".
Podríamos hacer lo mismo con este y obtener la respuesta más rápido pero, lo voy a hacer un poco más en general para que el
patrón sea más claro. Entonces "a" mas "b" por "a"
y a eso queremos restar "a" más "b"  por "b" ¿Si?
Esté más por este menos se hace menos y nos queda  "a" más "b" por "b" ¿Muy bien?.
Ahora lo que vamos a hacer es volver a usar la propiedad distributiva pero, ahora así,
que se distribuya sobre estos 2 y que este "b" se distribuya sobre estos 2. Nos queda "a" por "a" es "a" cuadrada
luego más "a" por "b" que es ab
luego -"b" por "a" que también es ab y -"b"
por "b" que es "b" cuadrada.
Simplificando podemos cancelar este con este, por que son iguales pero éste tiene signo - y nos queda "a" cuadrada
- "b" cuadrada. Entonces ahí está el patrón si tenemos la suma de 2 números
y la multiplicamos por la resta de esos mismos 2 números. Entonces nos queda el primero al cuadrado
- el segundo al cuadrado ¿Muy bien? Ahora sí vamos a aplicar
esto que acabamos de descubrir en este problema, donde dijimos que 2x era "a" .
Entonces aquí tenemos "a" más y 8 es "b", "a" más "b" entonces esté es "a" -"b".
Entonces qué nos quedaría, pues simplemente hay que aplicar directamente la fórmula. Nos queda "a" cuadrada o sea 2x al cuadrado
-"b" cuadrada o sea -8 al cuadrado
y esto ¿A cuánto es igual? 2x al cuadrado es 4x al cuadrado y 8 al cuadrado es 64,
entonces queda 4x al cuadrado -64.